antes de empezar con blindaje nuclear
repasemos algo de física digamos que
tenemos corriente en una espiral de
alambre en la izquierda está nuestra
espiral de alambre y digamos que la
corriente va en esta dirección es física
representas a la corriente con una y y
digamos que estamos viendo hacia abajo a
esta espiral de alambre esta de aquí
sería la vista sur
por
si vemos hacia abajo la corriente va en
sentido horario alrededor de esta
espiral en física la corriente es
pensada como cargas positivas moviéndose
aunque eso no es exactamente lo que está
pasando pero las cargas en movimiento
las cargas en movimiento provocan un
campo magnético así que la corriente
provocará un campo magnético podemos
saber la dirección del campo magnético
utilizando una variación de la regla de
la mano derecha si piensas en el caso de
la mano derecha estando justo aquí en
nuestra espira apuntamos nuestro pulgar
en la dirección de la corriente la
corriente va a la izquierda de este
punto apuntamos nuestro pulgar hacia la
izquierda esta será la parte de atrás de
mi mano derecha usando tu mano derecha
solo hay una dirección en la que tus
dedos pueden enrollarse y
en esta espiral tus dedos se enrollan
hacia abajo
así que en esta espiral tus dedos se
enrollan hacia abajo esa es la dirección
del campo magnético creado por la
corriente
y entonces de la vista superior en el
campo magnético entra a la página y si
le estamos viendo con esta orientación
el campo magnético iría hacia abajo el
campo magnético representado por una ve
aquí es creado por la corriente nuestra
espira de alambre la realidad es que los
electrones se están moviendo y ya que
los electrones están cargados
negativamente los electrones se mueven
en la dirección opuesta a la corriente
así que los electrones están de hecho
yendo alrededor de esta manera
si observar la vista superior los
electrones se mueven en sentido
antihorario esto es importante la idea
de mover los electrones creando un campo
magnético ahora veamos una situación en
la que tengamos un protón involucrado la
rm de un protón en el último vídeo hable
de cómo en la rm n de un protón aplicas
un campo magnético externo este vector
de aquí representa un campo magnético
externo ve 0 y en la presencia de un
campo magnético externo la densidad de
energía alrededor de nuestro protón
circula si piensas en esto como un
protón y piensas en algo de densidad de
electrónica yendo alrededor del protón
aquí hay algo de densidad de electrónica
circulando la densidad de electrónica
circulando genera un campo magnético
inducido
si los electrones se mueven en esta
dirección podemos pensar en esta
situación de aquí y el campo magnético
inducido irá hacia abajo por lo que el
campo magnético inducido se opone al
campo magnético aplicado aquí está el
campo magnético inducido déjame utilizar
un color diferente para eso aquí está el
campo magnético inducido este vector
está en la dirección opuesta a este
campo magnético
este efecto llamado 'día magnetismo y
entonces el protón el protón de aquí
experimenta un campo magnético total
menor
pensemos en eso si nosotros tenemos un
campo magnético aplicado de cierta
magnitud tenemos
0 y la densidad de electrónica
circulante produce un campo magnético
inducido que se opone
al campo magnético aplicado el protón va
a sentir un campo magnético total menor
déjame continuar dibujando esto aquí en
persona experimenta un campo magnético
menor al cual llamaré de efectivo
el campo magnético de efectivo que
experimenta el protón puedes pensar de
esta manera si empiezas con el campo
magnético efectivo experimentado por el
protón que sea igual al campo magnético
original el campo magnético aplicado
menos el campo magnético inducido y
entonces este protón este núcleo del
protón está blindado del campo magnético
externo por electrones este protón de
aquí se dice que está blind
y si incrementar la densidad electrónica
alrededor del protón entonces
incrementará el blindaje del protón el
blindaje el blindaje tiene el efecto de
disminuir el campo magnético afectivo
experimentado por el protón ahora
pensemos en dos ejemplos
primero empecemos empecemos con solo un
protón des blindado por aquí tenemos
únicamente un protón está completamente
deslindado no hay electrones alrededor
de él déjame escribir eso tenemos un
protón completamente ves
2 porque no hay electrones por lo tanto
este protón deslindado experimentará el
efecto completo del campo magnético
aplicado y sabemos del vídeo anterior
que el campo magnético aplicado el campo
magnético externo ocasionará que tus
estados de espn alfa y beta estén
separados por una cierta distancia aquí
aquí está el estado de spin alfa y aquí
está el estado de zinc beta
y esta será una cierta diferencia de
energía entre estos dos estados de espn
esta de aquí es la diferencia de energía
ahora movámonos al ejemplo en la derecha
en el ejemplo de la derecha este protón
de aquí el protón en la molécula está
blindado hay densidad electrónica
alrededor de este protón 10
este es un protón blindado déjame
continuar escribiendo eso protón me da 2
y acabamos de hablar de lo que eso
significa el protón blindado tiene
densidad de electrónica circulando que
genera un campo magnético que se opone
al campo magnético aplicado y entonces
el protón siente un campo magnético
mucho más pequeño disminuimos
disminuimos el campo magnético que
siente este protón
en el vídeo anterior hablamos de lo que
pasa cuando tienes un campo magnético
disminuido la fuerza del campo magnético
corresponde a la diferencia de energía
entre los estados de espín alfa y beta
así que para disminuir el campo
magnético comparado con el ejemplo en la
izquierda vamos a disminuir la energía
una disminución en el campo magnético
disminuye la diferencia de energía entre
el estado alfa y el beta puedo continuar
escribiendo esto cierto puedo mostrar
los estados alfa y beta aquí y puedo
mostrar un espacio menor entre ellos por
lo que hay una disminución en la energía
y sabemos que la diferencia de energía
es
es igual a h no
así que si disminuimos la energía vamos
a disminuir la frecuencia la energía y
la frecuencia son directamente
proporcionales por lo que la disminución
de la diferencia de energía disminuye la
frecuencia y entonces un protón blindado
absorbe a una frecuencia menor que un
protón deslindado por lo que un protón
deslindado en un protón deslindado la
diferencia de energía corresponderá a
una mayor frecuencia porque hay una
diferencia mucho mayor en energía
eso es en lo que necesitas pensar cuando
ves un espectro de mn y entonces solo
continúa dibujando rml genéricas estos
no son espectros de rm n reales solo
intento pensar en el ejemplo de estos
dos protones así que tenemos un espectro
aquí arriba esto sería déjame resaltarlo
esto sería el espectro deslindado y este
de abajo representa el espectro blindado
nuevamente no es un espectro de rm real
sólo ayuda a pensar en lo que está
pasando aquí y para el ejemplo en la
izquierda para el protón des brindado
pensemos en esto muy rápido mientras vas
a la izquierda en el espectro de rm n te
vuelves más y más deslindado y si estás
más deslindado experimentas un campo
magnético mayor
un campo magnético mayor un campo
magnético mayor corresponde a una mayor
diferencia de energía y una mayor
diferencia en energía corresponde a
absorber una mayor frecuencia así que
aquí se absorbe una mayor frecuencia y
por lo tanto mientras vamos a la
izquierda
estamos hablando de incrementar el
protón deslindado y esta señal que
aparece en tu espectro de rm en esta es
la señal para este protón deslindado
estamos hablando de una señal de
frecuencia alta si nos movemos a la
izquierda en el espectro de rm n estamos
hablando de una señal de frecuencia
mayor
hablemos del protón blindado de aquí en
la derecha estamos hablando del protón
bien dado ahora y mientras temores a la
derecha en tu espectro de rm n nos
movemos a la derecha en tu espectro de
rm m nos volvemos más y más blindados
esta señal es la señal para este protón
este protón está más blindado que el de
la izquierda cuando te mueves a la
derecha hablamos de aumentar el blindaje
y el aumentar el blindaje disminuye el
efecto del campo magnético disminuir el
efecto del campo magnético disminuye la
diferencia de energía entre el estado
alfa y el estado beta y por ende
disminuye la frecuencia absorbida
mientras te mueves a la derecha hablas
de señales de frecuencia más bajas
mientras te mueves a la derecha
estamos hablando de señales de
frecuencia más baja esta es la idea
s r m n
la cual introduje brevemente en el vídeo
anterior así que en la ts rn n estás
dejando al campo magnético externo
constante y está sometiendo a la muestra
con un pulso corto que contiene un rango
de frecuencias y entonces estas
frecuencias corresponden a diferencias
de energía una frecuencia podría
corresponder a esta diferencia de
energía y cuando el protón vuelve al
estado de energía menor la máquina de rm
lleva esta señal otra frecuencia podría
corresponder a esta diferencia de
energía y nuevamente la rm n te dará
esta señal y entonces esa es la idea de
la t efe rm n hacer todo esto al mismo
tiempo y la máquina de rm n te va a dar
tu espectro de rm m
para los espectros de rm n antiguos
mantendrás a la frecuencia constante y
variará la fuerza del campo magnético
para los espectros de rm n anteriores
resulta ser que mientras vas a la
derecha necesitas una fuerza de campo
magnético mayor por lo que llamamos a
esto campo arriba
este será un desplazamiento campo arriba
si quieres y mientras vas a la izquierda
en el espectro de rn necesitas una
fuerza de campo magnético menor y
llamamos a esto campo abajo campo arriba
y campo abajo son dos términos que
podrías escuchar y es terminología más
vieja relacionada a espectros de rm n
más viejos
pero aún son usados estoy segura que yo
aún no utilizo esos términos también en
este vídeo hemos hablado de dos protones
con diferentes cantidades de blindaje un
protón completamente deslindado
completamente deslindado y un protón
brindado aquí dos protones con diferente
cantidad de blindaje están en dos
ambientes diferentes y obtenemos dos
señales diferentes dos señales
diferentes teniendo frecuencias
diferentes en nuestro espectro de rm n
si tienes dos protones en el mismo
ambiente debería solo obtener una señal
y hablaremos más de esto en el siguiente
vídeo